[Applause]
indigenous women dancing alone in the
capital Brasilia to defend their lands
but also standing up for their rights in
tribal societies dominated by men
like Vari mama she left her marubu
Village in the Javari Valley to study
anthropology now she's struggling to
find a balance between fighting for
women's freedom and keeping ancestral
Traditions alive
security
our elders believe that if women leave
the village they'll marry a foreigner
and never return but I see it
differently I think knowledge and
understanding the outside world will
help us explain the importance of
preserving our culture and our forest
Anthropologist
who has been studying the marubo people
of the Javari Valley since the 70s says
feminism among the indigenous has come
to stay
Amnesia social media and cell phones
have closed the distances between men
and women from the most remote
indigenous territories and the rest of
Brazil women have found they have
similar causes fighting for equality and
the same opportunities as men the change
is inevitable it will take time because
not all men accept sharing power with
women but it's happening Brazil's first
indigenous Affairs Ministry is led by an
indigenous woman as is the government
agency funai responsible for protecting
the Brazilian indigenous population
when indigenous leaders started joining
forces to defend our lands women joined
the fight and started organizing
themselves as well I was the first
indigenous woman lawyer in Brazil and
the first congresswoman this helps in an
example for new generations that we can
occupy spaces in the political scene
back in the marubu Villages marriages
are still arranged and women are raised
to cook and take care of the children
while men leave the community
this is the main entrance of the long
house known as the maloka only men can
use it women have to go all around the
Hut to the back door where the kitchen
is now this is one of the many
Traditions that the maruba indigenous
people have still kept
however even in such a remote area
Customs are changing suvana marubo was
saved years ago from being married off
as a teenager when her mother sneaked
her out of the village and took her to
the city where she grew up
suvana has since returned with a mission
to empower Other Women by helping them
sell their crafts and arts
these traditional necklaces used to be
made out of shells now women are making
the same necklaces by recycling plastic
bottles and tubes brought to the Village
we're keeping our culture while adapting
to Modern Times
Silvana belongs to a Javari Valley
Women's organization that helps women
take their handmade products to art
fairs where they make their own money
suvana says it's a step towards their
independence without changing too much
their way of life